austin nominee elena carter no one was
more surprised than me that she said yes
can i tell you something can i tell you
what was happening in that obviously
that's the edited scene but i'll tell
you
we had a we had someone laurie the first
ad was operating a fart machine just off
to the right and that isn't a real
bathroom that was a bedroom in the house
because the the bathroom wasn't small
enough wasn't big enough sorry so
we took a bedroom and we converted it so
it's a prop toilet prop sink
etcetera and um
so we had laurie uh operating a fart
machine just off to my right here so
that we could have the occasional subtle
little
break of wind from heleno while she's
holding me hostage in the toilet and i
was doing the scene
and then
he was getting so trigger-happy it was
ridiculous i was trying to do lines and
it was
it was bloody ridiculous so in the end i
had to stop acting i looked over at him
and he wasn't pressing the button
and i went
and i looked behind me
it was princess margaret going off
like a tugboat behind me
genuinely farting
and i only i'd only just got over the
shock that helena bonham cartridge said
yes to my thing and then she was farting
within feet of me
and i went helena and she found it so
funny she found her own farting which
was magnificent i might say
she found her own farting so funny she
then worked herself
and had to leave the set
and while she was leaving the set she
was shouting at the top of her voice
it's natural
[Applause]
[Music]
you